our digital world depends on data and
this data needs to be analyzed in order
to provide key business insights SQL
allows you to manage relational
databases to do just that when it comes
to using technology to make on-the-job
decisions employers are demanding those
who can harness the power of sequel all
the biggest names in tech including uber
Netflix and Airbnb depend on either
sequel or no sequel databases to store
the data that fuels their decisions some
companies like Facebook Google and
Amazon have built their own high
performance database systems nonetheless
all these companies have data teams that
run queries on a sequel and no sequel
database systems to perform analysis in
Udacity is SQL nano degree program you
will learn to build manipulate and
analyze everything database and data
related with Udacity you will get an
in-depth instruction on leveraging the
power of SQL to pull insights from
relational databases and learn the
situational differences of using
relational databases versus non
relational databases like MongoDB and
Redis you won't just learn how to use
SQL you'll get hands-on experience with
projects including building a clone of
the popular social news aggregation and
discussion website reddit Udacity is
interactive workspace even allows you to
practice running Postgres SQL queries
using relatively large data sets master
SQL with a core language for data
analysis and enable insight driven
decision making for your business enroll
in Udacity SQL nano degree program today
you